[Music]
hi everyone i'm neil madden i'm the
author of api security in action and i'm
giving a talk at manning's conference on
apis and i'll be doing a deep dive into
oauth 2 scopes and how best to use them
to secure access to your apis
hi everyone my name is neil madden i'm
the author of api security in action and
today i'm going to be talking about 2
and particularly about old 2 scopes
and how you can best use those to
secure access to your apis so what is
oauth 2 so lots of you're probably
already familiar with oauth 2 but i'll
give it a very short refresher here in
case you've forgotten some of the
details
so the problem that oauth was originally
designed to solve you know over a decade
ago now was um
you know how if you've got a service
like linkedin that wants to
get access to your contacts in gmail say
so to see if you've got other colleagues
who are already on on linkedin
you know how do you give linkedin their
access without giving them your password
to gmail
in which case they could not only read
your contacts but also read all your
emails and and
send emails from your account
so we would like to not just rely on
linkedin being being well behaved here
we'd like to be able to actually say you
know you can only read my contacts
and so
oauth solves this problem then by um
instead of giving them your password you
you instead give them an opaque token
which is called an access token
which is a you know a short random
string that they can then use to access
the gmail api
and that token has associated with it a
scope which says what level of access
they should actually have
and so it looks a bit something like
this so you know you've got an app in
this case you know it's an app on your
phone but it could be an app running on
a server in the cloud or elsewhere
and you want to use that app to access
some of your resources on some api so
this might be the linkedin app that's
trying to access the gmail api to access
your contacts for instance
and then right so rather than asking you
for your password the app is going to do
it's going to talk to an authorization
services would be google's authorization
server in the case of gmail
and it's going to say you know i want to
be able to access this user's
contacts
and then the authorization server is
going to talk to that user so typically
through the the web browser on the on
the same device in this case and say you
know is it okay if this linkedin app
accesses your
contacts
and so that's the scope of access that
the app is asking for is is saying you
know i want read-only access to your
contacts then if the user approves that
then the authorization server will issue
this access token and optionally
something else called a refresh token to
the app
and then the app can use that access
token to access the the api
and that scope that's encoded into the
access token when you access the api
using that access token the api can
check that scope and say
you know
make sure your the app is not trying to
access anything that it shouldn't be
allowed to do according to that scope
so you know all these these four
entities have special names these are
their role names within oauth
so just recap this because it's
terms i'll use later on so the user then
is known as the resource owner so it's
assumed that it's their resources that
the app is trying to access and those
resources that live in the api live on
something called a resource service and
that's just the the name for the api
and then the app itself is the client
you know auth2speak
and then you've got the authorization
server so these four things so resource
owner resource server client and
authorization server
but what actually is a scope you know
this crucial thing that is defining the
level of access that an api has
um
that the client has to an api
is defined by this scope
so i'm not expecting you to read this
wall of text here by the way this is an
excerpt from rfc
6749 which um if that doesn't
immediately ring any bells that's the uh
oauth 2 specification
published in 2012.
which defines all of these flows and has
this short section here which which
talks about access token scope and what
this crucial scope parameter is so pull
out a few key quotes from here then so
it says the authorization and token
endpoints which are endpoints on the
authorization server itself
allow the client to specify the scope of
the access request using the scope
request parameter
okay but what actually is it then
and so it goes on to say the value of
the scope parameter is expressed as a
list of space delimited case sensitive
strings the strings are defined by the
authorization server
so that is pretty much all that the ol2
spec says about scope
which is not a lot i think you'll agree
but it says that they're strings so each
scope is a string
and what these strings mean is defined
by the authorization server and really
it's also defined by the resource server
which ultimately is going to enforce
these scope restrictions
okay so if the scope the spec doesn't
say much do other sources say anymore so
if we go to say oauth.net which is a
kind of central website for oauth so it
says the scope is a mechanism in oauth 2
to limit an application's access to a
user's account
an application can request one or more
scopes this information is then
presented to the user in a consent
screen and the access token issued to
the application will be limited to the
scopes granted so this gives you a bit
more hint about what it's what it's
intended for so
you know these these scopes are
decisions that a user is going to have
to make
about the level of access they want to
grab
and important as well in that is is the
idea that that scopes the client needs
to know ahead of time what scopes it's
going to have to ask for which suggests
that the
scopes must be documented somewhere so
there must be a kind of static list of
them somewhere that the app developer
can find out about
so let's look at some examples then
so if you look at google cloud platform
so this is google's you know cloud
offering has hundreds of apis you can go
and if you search for google cloud
platform oauth scopes
you'll find this page and they list you
know
dozens or hundreds of apis and all of
the individual scopes for those apis
that you can request from their
authorization server
and in this case google have decided
that these scope strings are going to be
uris
so they're not they're not urls i don't
think you can go and access these and
get anything particularly useful about
but they're uri so they're just kind of
structured identifiers
um and they've used uris just to make
them kind of unambiguous
they've kind of broken this down and you
get different types of api so here we've
got two on the right here we've got the
firebase rules api
which is a kind of infrastructure api
which is kind of used behind the scenes
and typically what's going to be
connecting to it will be some other
service so using some kind of service
account users wouldn't typically you
know directly care about this firebase
rules api
whereas underneath it here we've got the
fitness api which is all about granting
access to users individual fitness data
so things like their heart rate their
activity levels blood glucose
and things like this
and so this is much more about user data
and users are going to be much more
particularly
interested in in what kind of data is
shared from that api
and so you can see the fire ace rules
api just has a couple of scopes here has
three scopes
um so there's one that grants access to
to the whole api one that grants
read-only access and then there's this
other one
uh cloud platform that i'll talk about
in a minute
whereas the fitness api
you can't see it here on this screen but
it stretches down and there's
there's a couple of dozen i think scopes
defined by this api and they're much
finer level of access so
individual read and write access to
specific kind of
fitness indicators so activity blood
glucose
heart rate things like that
and so it's much more broken down so
when a user is going to have to make a
decision about what they allow access to
and when the user is going to care about
that decision then things are broken
down into a really fine grain level
otherwise they're left as a really broad
level
and there's also this interesting they
have this kind of god scope which is
this one right at the top here where it
says cloud platform which which in
theory grants access to the whole of the
cloud the google cloud platform
but in reality it doesn't because that
is limited by other authorization
mechanisms we will talk about this kind
of layering of oauth on top of other
authorization mechanisms later on in the
talk
so another example then if you look at
dropbox
file storage
so again they've got scopes as strings
but this time they're not using uris
they're using a kind of structured
string format
um
where they have uh typically like the
the resource that's being accessed like
account info or files or sharing
and then some kind of action that you're
going to perform on that so read or
write
they actually have very consistent use
of actions they use here so read write
list delete
modify
and then sometimes they break it down
even more so for files they say you know
can you access the content or just the
metadata
and so they have different scopes for
those things
but again it's quite similar to google
here you've got you've got the scopes
encoding you know what api you're
accessing and what what permissions
you're going to have on the api what
actions you can perform
so github another example here so here
again scopes are structured strings
they're a bit less consistent than
dropbox i suspect these scopes have kind
of evolved a bit more organically over
time
so sometimes you see you know
action colon resource and sometimes
you've got action underscore resource
and sometimes the action and the
resource are kind of switched around
so it's a bit less consistent here but
again it's got kind of got this this
thing that it's the scope is identifying
which api is being accessed
uh and what action you're allowed to
perform
so you know read user you can read it a
user's profile data
and then sometimes it's broken down to
specific fields like you know user email
which again you know the the read there
is kind of implicit there rather than
adding it on they have this uh
interesting idea of kind of hierarchical
scopes so rather than requesting access
to read user user email user follow
individually you can just request this
user scope which kind of implies the
others
which is quite an interesting um
approach
so if we look at these kind of
compare them we can see there's there's
a kind of common approach here
in that
the scope is encoding which api is being
accessed or which type of resources are
being accessed whether it's users or
messages or fitness or you know firebase
or whatever
and then the actions that are that are
being allowed whether that's read write
delete you know list modify whatever
and then sometimes they break it down
into more fine-grained specific fields
that you can have access to and that and
that's typically broken down then where
is something that a user is going to
care about the distinction there so the
user might not care that you know their
name but they might care a lot whether
you get their email address for instance
so is this enough is this if you're
going to use oauth2 to provide you know
to enforce your authorization to access
your apis is this enough information in
these scopes
you often see people who want to use or2
and just purely use oauth 2 scopes as
the only means of of
securing access to apis
um so let's let's have a look at an
example then so here's alice she's using
some kind of client and she's got an
oauth 2 access token
that she's approved with the
messages.read scope here
and then she makes a request to the api
to read her messages he's using this
access token
so she makes a get request to slash
users slash alice messages with his
access token or rather her client does
on her behalf
and gets back her messages
but then what if her client or her just
changes the alice in that in that uri to
to some other user id like bob and it's
quite common for the uris that you're
accessing an api to have
to have identifiers in them that that
are very easy to guess you can you can
guess somebody else's user identifier or
you know uh let's say it's a document
and it's using the database id which is
just a sequential number so you can
easily guess other other ids for other
documents
so you know
if we look at this if we just look at
the scope then the scope says
messages.read and it doesn't really say
it should only be alice's messages that
she can read and so if we're only using
the access token scope to grant access
then um we might have a problem here
and in fact people often do have this
problem and it's uh it's such a common
problem in in web application security
that it's got a special name and its
name is idor
and that stands for insecure direct
object reference
and this is the idea that
you're not really checking properly
what object somebody is trying to access
and so if they can guess the uri for a
different object
then they might be granted access to it
when they should have been denied so
here you know she changes alice to bob
in the uri
and because we're only checking that she
has the read read messages scope
then she gets back bob's messages
and this seems like a daft uh
kind of vulnerability but it's actually
so common that it was for a while it was
it had its own category in the owasp top
10. so if you're not familiar with the
owasp top 10 owasp is the open web
application security project and they
publish this top 10 periodically of the
most common web application
vulnerabilities so if you're if you're
new to application security it's well
worth kind of
uh
searching for that and having a look
so it's not the be all and end all of
security as i said but it's it gives you
an idea of what some of the most common
vulnerabilities are and what things to
look out for and this as i said this
used to be its own category it's now
been merged into a broader category of
uh broken access control
but it's it's this basic idea that if
you're not not
checking you know who has access to what
you're just saying you know something
like well they've got access to the
messages api and the read
um access
you know encoding this or2 scope then
they might be able to then read other
people's messages
so relying purely on oauth scopes for
authorization can lead to these kind of
ideal vulnerabilities because the way
that oauth scopes are typically designed
doesn't encode a lot of these extra
details about you know exactly whose
messages should be granted access to
so what are these other details
so if you look at the traditional kind
of components of making an authorization
decision
they kind of break down into these four
categories that are required to make a
good authorization decision so this is
uh information about the subject so who
is trying to perform this request who is
who is trying to get access to something
the resource what are they trying to
access is it some photos is it a
document is it you know
uh some payroll data or whatever uh what
action they're actually trying to
perform whether they're trying to read
or write or modify or delete
and then typically some environmental or
context-specific
information so you know where are they
trying to
gain access from you know are they are
they trying to access from home when
actually this is only allowed for
internal users on an internal networks
they
or are they accessing at a weird time of
day
and that feeds into some kind of
decision process that then makes is
going to make some kind of a loud denial
decision and here i'm not talking about
any specific technology for making that
decision
so this could be something like access
control lists or some kind of permission
system it could be role-based access
control or attribute based access
control or it could just be a bunch of
ad hoc rules that you've kind of hard
coded into your application but the
point is that you should be making a
decision based on
at least some of these broad categories
of
information
whereas when you try and just use oauth
scopes for this at least how they're
typically used
then you're you're throwing away a lot
of this information and you're only
getting some partial information to use
to make that request so you typically
you know the scope doesn't encode
anything about the user
typically because scopes are a static
list that you can go and read on the
documentation for an api
and they they don't typically encode the
user
uh they typically only encode part of
the resource so it will typically say
which type of resource is being accessed
but not which specific resource so you
know
if you've got a document read scope
which documents should you be able to
read
they do typically encode the action
pretty well
but they also then don't encode any kind
of context-specific
information about the request
so you're really limiting yourself if
you just use scopes
so could you encode all of that
information into scopes and i've seen
people try and do this and try and cram
every very complicated encoding schemes
where they try and cram all this
information into a scope
and in theory you know you could you
could try and do this you know strings
can be arbitrarily complicated you can
add whatever information you want but it
becomes you know much more difficult to
enforce this
and in particular when you think about
things like documents which are shared
resources that many users might have
access to
how is the authorization server supposed
to know who has access and and who
doesn't and what scopes are appropriate
and and not and the only way it's really
going to know that is by kind of
reaching into your data model behind the
scenes and kind of looking at
relationships between things and trying
to work out who should have access which
which kind of creates then a very tight
coupling between your authorization
server and the rest of your
your your applications and your apis
which can make things very brittle to
change over time
and you've also got to think about you
know what if those permissions change
after the token is issued when you issue
an access token to something like a
mobile app or something like a
tv set top box you know when you log
into netflix or something it
gets an access token that it's going to
use to access your your account
and those tokens can live for a very
long time
typically you know potentially multiple
years so
and so if you think about you know if
alice has access to this document when
when the token is issued is she still
going to have access to that document
two years down the line
because the scopes that are issued in
the token are fixed for the life of that
token
um and so um and if you try and
revoke the token uh when her permissions
change that means she's just gonna end
up having to log in again all the time
so uh so trying to encode too much into
scopes can make your application very
brittle
so there is a new specification coming
down the line which i'll just mention
briefly here it's called rich
authorization requests or ra
which is currently going through the
earth working group
which
enhances oauth with um
with this idea of authorization details
where you can pass in structured json
saying exactly what is being um
uh asked for
and in this case you know this can be
very very detailed unique
object for each transaction so it's kind
of designed for open banking and and
payment transactions and things like
that
so so in the future it might be possible
to do make these more kind of
fine-grained decisions purely based on
on this
scope thing but i would say that this
still has in my opinion some of the the
issues i just pointed out on the last
slide
so what should you be able to doing then
so um one thing you can think about
doing is layering oauth over some other
authorization mechanism so rather than
trying to do everything with scopes you
do some things with scopes and then
other things with a more traditional
authorization process
so you you yeah
a client accesses an api with an access
token you're going to validate that
access token check it's not expired or
whatever and check it was issued by
the correct authorization server
and then from that validation step
you're going to get back the the
scope of that token and who the resource
owner was and then you can check the
scope and say you know is that scope
appropriate for the re action that's
being performed against this type of
resource and if it isn't then you can
abort otherwise you go through to a more
traditional authorization decision where
you take the resource owner from that
access token so who originally approved
that access token and say you know would
they have access to this thing anyway so
if this is this is alice's access token
does she have access to bob's messages
well no so it would be denied there
where she does have access to her own
messages
and so you layer o-auth on top of an
existing authorization
process
so some key takeaways here then so so
keep it simple let's say you know
do this thing you don't try and solve
everything in oauth2 scopes
you know layer oauth on top of some
other
more fine-grained authorization
mechanism that's built into your app
itself built into your api
and and then keep it simple so follow
these these examples from google and
dropbox and github and so on because
they have converged on this common
approach
which is a kind of sweet spot for for
scope design
which is that you
use scopes only to distinguish between a
particular api or resource type
and the actions that can be performed
and you only break it down into more
detail where where that's a decision
that a user is going to care about so
particularly when sharing access to
their specific data
and avoid these idol vulnerabilities
these insecure direct object references
but making sure that you're not just
using the scope as the sole
indicator of whether whether a request
should be allowed
okay that's my takeaways for scope
design for security if you have any
questions um
ask in the chat and i'll um hang around
to take any questions thank you